my name is Andrew dhryn and I'm here to
talk about the state of go basically
what's happening in the go core at the
moment not in the community just in the
core I couldn't do the whole community
in 20 minutes that would be impossible
this talk is kind of built on the talk
that I gave previously at fast em in
February so if you've seen that I'm not
going to repeat much of it if you
haven't you can take a look at that to
see what you missed but primarily what I
want to talk about is just go 1.5 what's
going to be in the next release go 1.5
is scheduled for August 2015 so I think
it's the beginning of august so the
major work for 1.5 is already done we're
in what's known as the feature freeze
period which is just a three-month
period where we shake out any issues
that might be in the release before we
we cut it so one of the most major
changes to the core is that the
toolchain was converted from C to go so
the the old 6g AG etc compilers are now
just one go program called compile and
the same for the linkers the now a tool
called a link and there's a new
assembler that's actually a totally new
program so go 1.5 actually has no c code
at all in the tool chain or the runtime
which is really nice wait so you can
bootstrap the whole thing from just
having a working go installation go 1.4
or above but Rob is going to talk about
this in a lot more detail so i'll spare
you and so one of the marquee new
features viewers users is the new
concurrent garbage collector and this is
something that has been slated to be
part of go since its inception we've
always wanted to have a garbage
collector of this kind and now we
actually have one and it works which is
great so the goals were to limit pause
latency to under 10 milliseconds so the
previous garbage collector was a stop
the world mark and sweep collector
basically when a GC happened
while the GC is happening most of while
the GC is happening your program is
stopped and so depending on the size of
your heap and the type of allocations in
your heap you could be pausing for
anywhere up to seconds there were some
people with really large heaps of many
gigabytes who would have to endure
really long GC pauses but the new the
new GC it actually works by stopping
periodically and doing just clearing
parts of the parts of memory without
actually stopping everything at once so
this explains the new process basically
normally while your program is running
the GCS off point of rights go straight
through the memory as normal and then in
parallel I think there's a stop the
world phase only here so we do a stack
scan to collect what things pointed to
from the stack we do a mark process and
during the mark process there are right
barriers so any rights through pointers
are actually in or in directed through a
piece of code that tracks changes made
through those pointers and then for a
very short period we actually stop the
world and rescan anything that changed
during this phase and then and then we
just finished the mark process and then
we resumed your go programs execution
and then deallocate all the stuff that's
not in use I'm doing a pretty bad job of
explaining exactly how this works you
should watch Rick Hudson's talk at
gopher con to learn more about this
there's also the design doc at this URL
going bald / s / go 14 GC but basically
to illustrate the trade-offs being made
between the old GC and the new one we
basically spend a little bit more memory
and CPU time in exchange for much lower
pause latency and so in this old world
graph we have this is the this is the
garbage benchmark from the go benchmark
suite
and you can see here that the way the
collective work previously was with many
many stops each of which for about 80
milliseconds long in which the the
entire heap would have been scanned and
collected but now with the new collector
we still have many stops but this time
it's just these little Peaks that are
actually stopping the world and so we
actually only stopped for about one
millisecond each time we stopped and
then we have this longer collection
period where we're actually running
concurrent to the user program doing
some of the garbage collection then and
so we actually run alongside the user
program which is what it means by
concurrent in addition to the garbage
collector we've also been doing work on
the scheduler and so we have better
performance on when running across
multiple cores so if you set go max
props the environment variable to the
number of cores that you have in your
machine usually something like 4 or 16
or so on what you'll find is that the
performance is much better in go 1.5
then it has been previously so these
tables show various various benchmarks
running first with go max proxy equals 1
the default and then 2 4 8 12 and 16 and
we see the comparison between go one go
1.4 and 1.5 and what we see is in go one
point 0 and 1 point for running the
simple pry and see if benchmark which is
a program that calculates prime numbers
generating a lot of go routines some of
the work is parallel some of the work is
serialized as many Channel
Communications and so on in the original
version of go 1 point 0 it actually got
worse the more cause you used because
goroutines didn't have an affinity for
any particular CPU of so there was bad
cash locality and things with trash and
so on go 1.4 got a lot better I'm
particularly through the work of Dimitri
Volkoff who did some great work on the
scheduler
and made it quite great so you would
actually see improvements now we see we
still see a similar kind of improvement
in 1.5 but if you look at say one of the
worst case examples this chain example
is just launching many many go routines
and in serial passing a value through
each of them we can see that in go one
it was it just got a bit worse when you
edit extra seat views there was a jump
from 27 microseconds to 300 something
and you'll see that it got a bit worse
in 1.4 but not as bad but you see and go
1.5 it barely gets worse at all it
doesn't change an order of magnitude it
only goes up by a couple of microseconds
from 36 and it remains stable so our
schedule is much more improved for not
parallel kind of work as well but if you
look at those are micro benchmarks that
are only indicative of kind of special
case behaviors if you look at practical
workloads like running mag dash building
the go tool chain or listing all the
files in the standard library or running
the HTML template tests you can see that
we actually see practical improvements
by setting go max brooks so make both
Bosh gets a bit faster but it was
already using multiple pause to build
packages anyway so that's why it only
gets a little bit faster with go list is
actually a mostly io bound operation and
you'll see that it just gets a little
bit better but only marginally and
running the HTML template tests we do
see an improvement but that's not a
particularly parallel operation either
and in general in our batch bug sweet
everything just gets better so bottom
line is go 1.5 works better on
multi-core machines which is great
significantly better this is just a
graph that talks about go go 1.5
performance against go 1.4 across all of
our benchmarks weeds so this the
vertical axis is the gia mean geometric
mean of performance
of the benchmarks together and it goes
back to mid-april when a bunch of the
concurrent GC work had been in the tree
things are a bit worse we added a few
more things disabling debugging somehow
made it worse we don't actually know why
when we introduced multi-threaded
concurrent GC and change the way the
garbage collections are triggered it got
worse again and then we fixed the
failure whether GC wasn't triggering and
so we've got slower again but then work
was done to improve caching of GC work
to improve the right Barry code to
improve the scheduler and to fix a bug
and now we're actually back up with on
average better performance than we had
in 1.4 so it's not significantly better
than 1.4 in general but it's it's it's
slightly faster or the same and we can
actually see our entire benchmark suite
here you can see all of the things most
of which got slower some of them
dramatically slow slower sorry most of
which got faster some of which
dramatically faster like this it's
really the binary thing it's just a bit
flipped in my brain yeah a lot of the
regular expressions I've got faster one
of them got a bit slower but you can see
that on aggregate things are more or
less the same if not better okay so
that's performance go and put 5s and new
operating system and architecture
support we now can build on iOS devices
so Darwin arm also there's arm 64
support so we can run on 64-bit ARM
cores which includes the newer iPhones
and iPads and also some of the server
grade machines that are out there I
think there might be some I'm 64 android
stuff I'm not sure anyone know
I don't know yeah we also support linux
when I'm 64 which has seeger which is
nice for the servers and we support arm
on openbsd which i think is it sorts in
its early stages we retired support for
dragonfly bsd on 386 because they drop
support for it and similarly apple
doesn't support OS 10 10.6 and so we
made the policy decision not to support
snow leopard anymore which doesn't mean
that it doesn't work although I think at
this moment it doesn't work it just
means that we're not going to try hard
to make a work another significant
feature is shared library support in 1.5
so it means that you can build go
libraries as shared libraries and then
link them from go programs so if you run
go install with build mode equals shared
you can build the standard library as
shared libraries and then you can build
a hello world program that links against
those shared libraries so i can give you
a demo here i have a hello world program
it just does not links again puts the
funk package if i look in my package
linux [ __ ] underscore shared you can see
oh no I know it's not called shared it's
called
mmm it's not going to work now see I
should be able to build with build mode
equals shared the hell logo file okay
my dim yeah I'd actually did this demo
just before I got here anyway you can
see that if I had done that's what would
happen and you get a 13 k go binary the
links against all the objects response
and so the primer like I I don't
envision really using this myself but on
I know that part of the work for doing
this has been done by employee of
canonical and they have an interest in
packaging go programs for debian and
ubuntu and their package got packaging
guidelines require that each dependency
is packaged individually and so this
actually enables them to you know
individually packaged each part of a go
program and not duplicate parts of not
duplicate libraries that are used by
multiple things so that's quite nice and
you can learn more about those execution
modes with that with if the design
document also included in those is the
ability to build to see archive files
and shared libraries and so you can
build a go program or a go library as an
object file that you can include from C
programs so if you have a package P you
just put a sigo import statement here
just importing the package capital C
which is a magic package and then you
could put an export comment above the
functions that you want to be accessible
from C and then you write a main package
that imports that package and the main
function is just ignored so you just
leave empty main and then if you run go
build with build mode equals C archive
you get object files and a header file
which you can link to from C programs
and so when you link against that bode
when the see program starts any of the
init functions in your GoPro in your go
code will be executed in the in the
packages go home but the main will not
be executed but then you can just call
into
and these functions and so go code can
now be called into from sailors cleaners
and that's used on mobile as one one
place it's used and I can imagine a lot
of people have uses for it as well if
you want to add go code to some legacy
projects for instance there is a minor
language change you can now omit the key
type from a map literal so if you have a
map of points to some value and point is
a struct previously you had to write
like this and now you can just write it
like that so you know serious business
the goat all used to have a go doc
subcommand and all it would do is show
you the package documentation for your
package but now it has there's been
resurrected it was removed in 1.4 and
it's been resurrected for 1.5 and re
implemented as a nice command-line
interface to go doc so you can say go
doc and then just the package name
identifier and it will match against all
the packages in your go path and find
one that ends in that package name and
it doesn't match on case sensitivities
so you don't have to get the case right
all the time and if you just put if you
just give it a name on its own then it
will look in the current package in the
current directory so for instance you
know I'm in this this package here
package audio if I say go doc I get the
whole package but if I say you want to
find out more about the engine type i
can say go doc engine shows me the
method
the documentation and you know if I
wanted to learn about thumbprint you
know I can find it so that's quite nice
there's a new execution tracer in go 1.5
which allows you to it's basically like
a heavy duty profiler that basically
writes out everything that your program
does it doesn't use simply sampling as
as the old one does it actually love
everything and so your program runs a
bit slower but then you can use the
there's this trace viewer that was done
by the Android and chrome teams and it
lets you generate traces like this in a
user interface that you can navigate so
you can hear I've clicked on GC and I'm
looking at the the GC characteristics
this is with the old stop the world
collector this is not a a newer one so
you can see this will improve but then
you can see for go for threads running
across and CPUs and all of the go
routines executing on those you can
click through and see what's happening
so this is going to be really useful for
understanding go programs so yeah you
can learn more here going dog / yes / go
15 trace of course we have more analysis
from refactoring tools some of these is
it here being around before like the
Oracle but now there are plugins for
sublime text in Emacs so that you can
you know click through identifiers and
navigate source code and learn more
about you know where a particular
identifier is used or you know if you
have a channel you can look at what what
values are sent on that channel and so
on go doc also has some of that magic in
it you can run go to up with a pointer
analysis flag and see all those details
about how code is you so makes the go
documentation a lot richer and the
source code view a lot richer and we
have a couple of refactoring tools which
there's a lot to say about them so i
won't go into them now
much time but they're definitely worth
taking a look they're all in the go
tools sub repository Brad and I and a
few other people have been hacking on
the continuous build infrastructure and
that we use for testing go across a
variety of platforms it's now running
Linux Windows OS 10 free VST openbsd
plan 9 builders all on Google compute
engine so when someone commits a new
change to the go call we actually spin
up machines to run builds across all of
those platforms and so will spin up like
20 30 instances and build and then just
shut them down when they're done oh yeah
so OS X is running in it in a kind of
different way where we have a bunch of
what machines that connect to our build
coordinator and they say I'm available
for doing OS 10 builds and now we're
using VMware on on OS 10 that almost so
at the moment we're just doing builds on
those machines but we plan to actually
spin up OS ten instances inside VMs on
those OS 10 machines be nice of Apple
lettuce virtualized that somewhere else
like on a cloud product that we can't
and for doing builds of Andrew on
Android devices and on iOS devices we
actually have a bunch of those devices
plugged into a bunch of machines running
that same software and we farm the work
out of them as well and the nice thing
about doing it this way is we're able to
shard the execution of tests across
multiple machines so when we're doing
dealing with slower hardware our Ted
where our test suite would normally take
a full hour to run see we can actually
split it up into like half a dozen
different stages and you know give tests
a through n two to one group and you
know ell students so on through to
another group which is really nice and
that also enables us to more practically
do try bots where we can have a pending
change and test that it works and I'm
actually going to do a little hacking on
some of the go build process now because
it's a good time to do it I guess
so here's a put something in in Maine I
don't know why it's called x-men in fact
doesn't even have to be real girl code
that'll do yeah I don't care yeah that
will work i'm sure i'll send it to Ross
Oh pre submit checks all right fine
Nelson's been editing my code all right
so
and I'll mail that to Russ
so this is uploading the change to our
code review system Garrett I can open
this URL in code review system and see
my change great i'm going to click this
run try bot button and post that and
then within i don't know a short time we
should see some change so i can actually
see this is this is the farmers user
interface well status page which is
saying that it's trying my build and
that's running on a linux arm process
that can't be right couldn't have got
that far brad says i should just ship it
it hasn't kicked in yet come on yep if
one of my demos works i'll be happy if
this one doesn't work I don't well I can
come back to it anyway I don't need to
only you know we don't need to see it
happen right now oh here we go try
what's beginning so now I can look at
that status page this is the tripod
status one's already failed the Darwin
one has failed yeah it looks like
they're all doing badly and now I'm
seeing more info from there it says it
should failed on Darwin amd64 it's not
going to tell me about each one that
fails and then it's just going to wait
for them all to fail before I get the
final report which should be soon 13
builds remain 12 nice thing as you can
see you can actually see streaming build
output from the machines right all of
them as soon as it happens but it's
already ha come on Belle found
seven bills remain and so on anyway when
that's all broken it will tell me that
it's that it's bad what does Brad see
never mind this brought the bills and I
will abandon it don't know what I was
thinking sorry alright so that's really
useful for us because often you'll make
a change and you know you won't know you
don't have time to manually test if you
want to test it across everything it's
great and finally mobile so 1.5 supports
good support for Android and
experimental support for iOS so this is
I don't have an iOS device well I have
one but I don't have one that I have the
dev stuff set up for but this is it
running a go program I got a colleague
to send me a photo of that so it's real
it's not had enough faked you'll have to
take my word for it I guess but one of
the nice things about the the android
support is that we have this going
mobile tool which is like the go-to what
for doing mobile development and who
here is set up an Android SDK before and
keep your hand up if it was easy all the
hands went down only one person kept it
off but yet it can be a bit confusing
and difficult but to set up the android
sdk for go use type go mobile in it and
it downloads the toolchain everything in
sets it all up I'm not through doing
general Android development just for
doing go on Android development and then
once you have a go mobile app you just
run go mobile install to build the apk
and uploaded to your device so the
workflow is very similar to just writing
normal go programs and also there is the
go mobile bind command which lets you
build a shared library that you can use
in a java android app or an objective-c
iOS app so you can you know if you want
to ride your networking coding goes it
has quite nice network libraries and go
routines are a great way for writing
network for
you can do that and still do all of your
you i work in iOS or android zone sorry
in java or objective c but so i can give
you a demo of this I've written this
flappy gopher which is not a full game
but it's this the source code people
like it when i turn on syntax
highlighting I've learned only took five
years to realize that but basically I
have set up an appt put the noggin
transplantable API but I create an app
and run it with these two callbacks
drawer and touch and so the draw
function it sets some some GL crap and
renders the scene which is set up
somewhere else it ever anyone has anyone
done OpenGL programming would you agree
that it's GL trap it's not just yeah and
then I have something that calculates
the position of things and then handles
touch events there's a lot more to say
about that but I don't have time so if I
if I won't go install locally it builds
a version of this that actually runs on
my local machine so you can see that
basically it's like I'm supposed to
avoid this thing I don't know why it's
so big it must be the resolution in the
display it's supposed to be much bigger
but if i run if i plug my android device
in and then make sure it's switched on
and run go mobile install please give me
giving my last demo
so you can see it's running it's linking
that's running a DB to upload and yep
it's done now I have this main icon here
and I tap that and i have my gopher
running on the thing so that's the kind
of you know write compile test cycle
that i like to see so I'm very excited
about that personally if I just want to
talk a little bit about the NGO
community events that are coming up
there's gokon the organizer which is
here organizers and that's in Tokyo next
month's anyone going to that apart from
you guys yeah Francesca speaking there
there's also go for con in Denver who's
going to go for con way that's cool it's
like a quarter of you great um and
Gotham go is in New York and October
anyone going to that why would you go
over there you you might yeah why not I
don't know if there's a real East Coast
West Coast me I really I mr. a lien on
it and also there's another dot go as it
was last year in parents and I know
there's at least a couple more
significant events that are going to be
announced all right thank you very much
so I do have some time for questions so
raise your hand someone will bring your
like that's someone to the plans just to
kind of continue down the projector e
that we're going now to build some nice
libraries for basically building games
some of the libraries that I used there
were a sprite package and there's also
an audio package come for doing just
cross-platform 3d and audio stuff and
handling touch events and all that kind
of stuff just basically getting that to
a nice sort of Polish state and then I
guess we'll see where we're at from
there and there's no kind of like
massive overarching roadmap but you know
particularly in speaking to people who
were kind of in the the game sphere and
also people who just want to you know
write libraries for apps we know that
people really want to use go so I just
want to make that possible yeah yeah so
like yes so you know if you write Java
apps or iOS apps the chances are you
want to include some go code maybe you
want to share some code between your
server side and your your perhaps if you
ride that pony go we want you to be able
to use that on those platforms and so a
lot of the work involved there is really
just finessing that whole process we'd
like the go mobile talk to support I
else in the same way it does and right
now and we think that's that's a nice
thing to have and that's what we're
shooting for
hey with respect to the library to
shared object loading all right they
shared to vibration is passed in
computers on channels that's actually a
good question i think if you use the
shed object mode you do share the same
go run time between different go shared
libraries but if you use the c archive
mode where you basically build an entire
go program that's linked I think you
don't but don't quote me on that it
might be the same in both cases in which
both get separate runtimes
so the go global stuff is super awesome
do you have plans to degrade poorly
separate component cities in the court
you mean using it on not mobile
platforms like other place here it runs
Android
Oh
I mean if you're talking about embedded
in the sense of something you can run
linux on then you can already probably
run go there and particularly if it's an
arm you most likely can for mips and
stuff like that you can use GCC go but
as far as like library support for doing
embedded stuff i know there are people
that have done like gpio libraries for
doing i owe on pins and stuff like that
and so there are already people doing
that kind of work so what you want may
already exist
let's save a couple Googlers were
writing a cross-platform glee vibrating
go secondly announced at home in five a
couple of Google is a writing one yeah
it's a cross-platform green light all
right i'm dimly aware of it as you can
tell so I can't say anything about that
fine ok so we're going to you they're
gonna thank you